we've been back to this map many times
and battles going fits and starts but
this one is now starting to show some
movement the Russians have tried to uh
take back much both from the frontal
attack from the east from the north but
now they've gone round to the South and
they may be having some success when I
say the Russians I'm talking about the
Wagner group The Mercenary group who are
determined to take back motor though it
doesn't have a great deal of strategic
value but they've got this ground to the
South they're probably only about four
or five kilometers away but it's all
very open ground and they're having to
attack across very open country the
ukrainians are hitting them night and
day with artillery so much so that the
Pentagon is even worried that the
ukrainians are using up too much
artillery in defending Batman the
fighting around there is absolutely
ferocious I was looking at some footage
overnight of night attacks uh that the
Wagner group were trying across this
open ground and it just somebody said
it's a vision of hail it's just alive
with fire and Flame all night long um
we'll see how that goes I mean the
Russians may get towards the outskirts
of Batman but my goodness they're paying
a price for it and the issue is even if
they take back mud it won't matter if
they lose a cremena further north and
that's where the essence of the rest of
this battle will take place the Russians
occupy cremer and satova further north
of that that's the main communication
lines the ukrainians have been attacking
cremator in particular in recent weeks
and it looks as if the ukrainians are
now having some real success they got
around partly to the the South but in
the north they've got round and they've
taken their Chevron
is actually quite a small village but
it's very important because it allows
the ukrainians to get to encircle most
of cremena than cremena will fall and if
cremena falls that becomes effectively
the hinge that will open up Northern uh
luhansk and in particular may allow may
allow the ukrainians to start to get
around the back of of Russian forces in
svari donets unless
those places 100 days the Russians tried
taking severed on yesterday which they
eventually did and they took the
shashanski a bit more quickly after that
but if they're losing cremena if they
give up cremena then the ukrainians have
got a much clearer run to try to make
big inroads into Russian defenses and if
they lose the p-66 highway which they
have already lost control of then the
Russians have been pushed back about 30
kilometers east to starobilsk before
they can really establish a new another
line to dig in so things are getting
very very critical for them at cremena
if the ukrainians can keep up the
momentum of their attacks meanwhile we
still think about how the Russians are
reacting to these attacks on air bases
the the air base the diaglivo air base
up in riazan uh the Engels 2 air base
and Saratov and the near the air base in
cursed it wasn't actually out there base
it was a uh a fuel dump that was in
between the airport and the air base
itself the point is the damage in these
three places wasn't great but but the
fact that they were attacked at all is
really important now the state
department in the last 24 hours have
made it very clear there's nothing to do
with them they were not attacked with
American weapons or weapons that the
Americans have given to of the
ukrainians these were apparent attacks
with ukrainians own weapons weapons that
they have adapted that they don't have
any role in the plannings nothing to do
with them it's very important that the
Americans make it clear that this is a
ukrainian-only attack meanwhile
President Putin is dealing with some
very angry people on Russian telegram
channels who are Furious that that a
apparently a drone a 1970s drone an old
Soviet Red Army drone was used
apparently in these attacks so deep into
Russian territory I wasn't intercepted
and that's a big problem President Putin
met with his Security Council yesterday
he hasn't said anything yet today we
will see if there's some sort of
retaliation or some sort of response
that comes out of it but above all
President Putin has now got to deal with
the increasing anger inside Russia just
in military circles but in the media
that these attacks could take place at
all in a conflict that is still supposed
to be a special military operation to
remove the government in Kiev we've got
a long way to go yet